la plus grande hantise des clients
pendant les soldes c'est de ne pas
trouver la bonne taille grâce à la salle
de machines installées à vélizy 2 vous
allez pouvoir connaître vos mensurations
exact l'intérêt c'est que c'est d'une
part une innovation c'est quelque chose
qui ne s'est jamais monté dans les
centres commerciaux du moins en france
c'est en plus un service pour les
clients ce que ça permet de gagner du
temps en cabine on connaît directement
sa taille dans plusieurs magasins en
venant ici
et puis et puis en plus c'est une
animation ça fait vivre le centre les
clients sont à sont intéressés sont
curieux et viennent volontiers l'essayer
donc depuis ce matin ça ne désemplit pas
une caméra l'intérieur de la salle des
machines calcul vous mensurations
quelques minutes plus tard vous avez
vous en faut en 3d avec votre taille
votre silhouette et les vêtements
adaptés à votre morphologie des
informations importantes qui séduisent
les premiers utilisateurs
déjà on a l'impression d'être dans un
truc futuriste le truc bouge tout seul
c'est assez marrant à faire et puis
c'est sympa puisque maintenant j'ai ma
taille dans toutes les boutiques delà de
la galerie donc je sais directement vers
quoi me diriger donc c'est plutôt sympa
ben c'était marrant c'était marrant à
faire en fait le plateau bouge donc on a
au départ on s'y attend pas mais c'est
sympa vous pouvez utiliser la size
machines tous les week-ends durant les
soldes à vélizy 2 et parly 2